it's good to be here I flew in from New
York yesterday I've been only flying on
Spirit Airlines this year it's like oh
yeah everybody hates me I love it it's
like Medicaid for the sky you know it's
sick
I flew I'm spear with you later for $34
is that crazy nobody can beat 34 right
34 so cheap that even if it crashed it's
like still kind of a good deal yeah I
wouldn't complain about it you guys it's
going down and be like yeah what did I
think was going to happen it should
crash for sure it's been 34 dollars to
fly in the air that doesn't make a lot
of sense
I wouldn't like tip the pilot you know
hey hey they taking care of you big guy
are you an uber pilot why is this so
cheap I was flying to Indiana which
should be free it's read you have to pay
to go to Indiana it should be like
should be free I'm from Indiana
so I'm trash thank you for having me
yeah my whole family loves guns I'm torn
on guns you know cuz they're dangerous
and stuff but I'll admit that it would
be fun to have a gun like wouldn't be
kind of cool to have a gun you know not
even to use it but just like Instagram
right like post a picture like gotta go
to the bank on my way to meet my in-laws
Mike's come on no I I live in Brooklyn
now which is fun except for I get
heckled on the street all the time so
I'm like ethnically ambiguous like I was
sitting in the park of the day trying to
meditate and this guy yelled at me go
back to Guatemala
he said Guatemala that's so specific man
that's like a racist Hail Mary to throw
you know you think of that lands that
dudes going back to Guatemala tonight
it's over for that dude I'm not from the
beautiful land of Guatemala I'm half
Indian in case you're trying to guess
yeah half Indian sometimes I tell people
that they'll say this fun thing were
they like
oh you're Indian huh feather or dot yeah
feather a fun flirty way to marginalize
two cultures with two words how
efficient I'm gonna start doing that to
white people yeah next time you see a
white person would be like oh you're
white huh potato or not see big potatoes
in the room no I am yeah I am a dad it's
fine who I should say I am a dot by the
way I know it's bothering some of you
you might notice I don't have an Indian
accent at all because my father left
before I ever heard his voice so this is
my god I've had four different Indian
people come with me after shows recently
and be like hey man your dad probably
left because there's a lot of pressure
and Indian culture to not have like
mixed-race children it's like a weird
thing but he's probably just like
ashamed or something I'm just like oh
cool thanks
good news but I feel much better this
mystic convo I'm glad we had it yeah man
my name is Tom Thakkar my that's my
father's name my name used to be Tom
Brady and I had to change it because
apparently there's this guy who sucks
and I was a bad name for comedy I was
getting booed in sports towns like I did
a show in Indianapolis Indiana where the
Colts play and there was a white rapper
hosting the show which is what you hope
for that's like the gold standard in
comedy this guy saw my name on the list
of comedians and his eyes lit up and he
went up to the mic and he was like oh
man y'all red even gonna believe what's
about to happen now we Colts fans in
here right and they were like whoo he
was like and we all hate the damn
Patriots right yeah then he said I swear
to God
who is the biggest little punk-ass [ __ ]
you could think of who plays will the
Patriots and all together like they had
been practicing it before I got there
it's like a weird prank they were like
Tom rhyming and then he just goes yeah
here he is
[Music]
and then they all started booing and he
just handed me the microphone it was
like hey good luck man sorry about that
I don't know why that happened that's
weird
have a good little show all right thank
you guys very much you guys astray
you